modern horror movies often go overlooked
but from time to time a spectacularly
terrifying film takes a public by storm
perhaps 2017 is a year that happens
again and any number of the following
horror movies could do it here are all
of the horror movies that will blow
everyone away in 2017 split this could
be the year that M night Shyamalan
career experiences a renaissance and
after flops like The Last Airbender he
really needs it his latest film splits
is loosely inspired by the true story of
Billy Milligan the first person to be
acquitted of a major crime because of
his multiple personality disorder
filmmakers have been trying to bring
Milligan story to life on the big screen
for years and now Shyamalan is making it
happen James McAvoy still bald from
x-men apocalypse stars as Kevin who
suffers from dissociative identity
disorder in what could be a long-awaited
return to form for Shyamalan Resident
Evil the final chapter Milla Jovovich is
back for the long-awaited final
installment in the Resident Evil movie
series despite falling victim to the
video game movie curse the franchise
continues to turn a profit and will
likely do so again with Resident Evil
the final chapter in this ultimate
installment releasing in late January
Alice and her band of survivors will
make their final stand against the
umbrella corporation and the undead in
the dreaded Raccoon City where five
movies and over 20 games deep so why
stop now rings over a decade after the
ring too was released in the theaters
paramount is bringing it back for a
third installment simply titled rings
which takes place thirteen years after
the events of the first movie since VHS
isn't really a thing anymore it's now a
digital video that will kill you in
seven days which is pretty much the
worst computer virus ever do you want to
destroy humans please say no okay I will
destroy humans no I don't destroy humans
the twist there's a part of the deadly
video that no one's seen until now so
expect completely new levels of chaos on
even more drippy horror children On
February 3rd a cure for wellness you
might not expect a horror movie from the
guy who direct
Rango but Gore Verbinski is going back
to his horror roots with his next film a
cure for wellness on February 17th he's
turning the tables are making a
psychological horror starring Dane
DeHaan and the naturally terrifying Mia
goth
the film follows two hands mr. Lockhart
as he attempts to retrieve his company's
CEO and escape from a mysterious
Wellness Center in the Swiss Alps of
course this isn't a feel-good film about
getting one's groove back and the
Wellness Center doesn't really have its
customers best interests at heart
two psychological terror ensues get out
yeah sorry man marking the directorial
debut of comedian Jordan Peele best
known for Comedy Central's key and Peele
gets out follows an interracial couple
as they visits a town where black
residents have begun to go missing
starring Daniel Kazuya Allison Williams
Catherine Keener and Erica Alexander
jets house is being produced by Blum
House productions who rarely makes bad
horror movies just look at their slates
Paranormal Activity insidious the purge
and sinister are just some of their
iconic films moving from comedy acting
to horror directing is a big leap but
early buzz surrounding this film's
February 24th release is all positive
personal shopper though she'll always be
best known as Twilight's Bella Swan
Kristen Stewart continues to make a name
for herself in numerous independent
films next up is a french maid
psychological thriller personal shopper
which follows Stewart as Maureen who's
employed as a personal shopper for a
German model the twist when she's not
buying stuff for pretty people she's
trying to contact her dead brother Louis
where those two things meet is anyone's
guess but surprisingly the film earns
the Best Director award at the 2016 camp
in for the film gets a wide release on
March 10th alien covenant featuring the
return of Michael Fassbender and
featuring Katherine Watterson Billy
Crudup
and Danny McBride director Ridley Scott
is finally bringing his Prometheus
sequel alien covenant to theaters this
year this isn't to be confused with a
new alien film stuck in development
house since 2002 and directed by Neill
Blomkamp which is supposedly following
later we're still in pre a lien
continuity here although Scott's
original idea was to explore the
mysteries left and answered in
prometheus with new Mira Paz returning
as Elizabeth sure things have taken a
different turn instead of directly
following the events of Prometheus alien
covenant will follow a new crew aboard a
new ship whose paths will intersect of
the survivors of the Prometheus meet the
new xenomorphs on May 19th The Mummy
even Universal Pictures is climbing
aboard a cinematic universe trained
since they don't have a catalogue of
comic book properties they can sift
through they're mounting their shared
universe around the iconic monsters that
made them a worldwide brand beginning
with Alex Kurtzman as the mummy on June
9th starring Tom Cruise sofia boutella
and Russel Crowe as dr. Henry Jekyll the
mummy ignores a delightful Campina sub
Brendan Fraser's previous mummy trilogy
and instead brings a film back to its
horror roots the new film also takes a
franchise in a new direction by setting
it in the present day and featuring a
new mummy taking down him hotep three
times was more than enough Amityville
The Awakening the June 30th for a lease
of frank coffins Amityville The
Awakening will mark the 18th movie based
on the haunted house since a series
inception in 1979 each installment in
the Amityville franchise just adds to
the weird continuity nightmare which has
been played with prequels pre sequels
and an occasional lawsuit
you probably know what to expect with
the new Amityville chapter a single
mother and our three kids and knowingly
move into the infamous one-one-two Ocean
Avenue house and terror ensues worst
realtor ever you should always put
bleeding walls in the listing some
people might even like that kind of
thing make the walls bleed no I don't
have to tame you come on do it
do the blood thing come on do it do it
do it do it Anabelle - in 2013 the
conjuring surprised audiences by
effectively reinventing age-old scare
tactics and was popular enough to
warrant a spin-off that movie Annabelle
focused on the origins of the Tara doll
made famous buddy original now Annabelle
is becoming its own horror series
because honestly she's pretty freaking
scary the new installment follows a nun
and a group of young girls who move into
a doll maker's home and because it's a
horror film is the same house in which
the doll maker's daughter died 20 years
prior Annabelle finds a fresh set of new
victims on August 11th it's Hollywood
loves adopting Stephen King's works a
miniseries based on the novel it aired
on television in 1990 starring Tim Curry
as penny wise but that just wasn't
enough for fans of Nightmare clowns
a cinematic version of it is due to hit
theaters on September 8th but because of
production challenges and the change
interactor the production's original
star will Poulter will no longer be
playing penny wise his replacement bill
skarsgård seems pretty terrifying but
he's got some big Tim Curry slide shoes
to fill at liners years before Joel
Schumacher destroyed Batman he brought
Peter Filardi science fiction horror
film Flatliners to the silver screen the
film follows five medical students as
they voluntarily subject themselves to
near-death experiences in order to
discover what lies in the afterlife now
27 years later a sequel is in the works
also titled Flatliners starring Ellen
Page Diego Luna and the Nina Dobrev with
Kiefer Sutherland returning from the
original movie a plot summary hasn't
been released yet but you can expect a
whole lot of almost dying and maybe a
little bit of actual dying too on
September 29th Friday the 13th
Warner Brothers originally commissioned
to Friday the 13th sequel in 2009 but
the studio cancelled the project before
relinquishing the rights to Paramount
Pictures so they could co-produced
Christopher Nolan's interstellar fans
were disappointed but paramount
immediately began working on their own
Friday the 13th movie according to
reports the new film will be an origin
story featuring the return of Jason's
mother and was reportedly almost some
deranged version of Dazed and Confused
meets Jason as if this wasn't creepy
enough they say me
what's more this will be the third team
Finn's torment in the Friday the 13th
franchise which will also release on
Friday the 13th
this October insidious chapter for James
1 is truly the modern master of horror
having created the saw conjuring and
insidious franchises today he's
directing things like Furious 7 and DC's
upcoming Aquaman film but despite his
exit from the insidious franchise it
continues to prosper so much that film
district order the fourth installment to
be directed by Adam Roberto and written
by franchise co-creator Lee were now not
much is known about the film at this
time except for its strategic October
release date sword legacy when the Saw
franchise began in 2004 one installment
was released every year until 2010 and
then nothing now seven years later it's
back for one last chapter with so legacy
directed by the spirit brothers so why
are they bringing sore back after all
these years the filmmakers originally
intended saw 3d to be the final
installment in the long-running
franchise
however when saw six underperformed at
the box office
Lionsgate approved one more movie which
hindered the filmmakers plans and left a
franchise of an unsatisfactory twist and
more questions than answers
so legacy releasing on October 27 will
hopefully answer some of those lingering
mysteries as well as we invent the
franchise thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]